tell me once again that you understand I
could be the man let me hold your hand
stick to the plan forget that I was 19 I
moved out here I actually I started
going to a community college in Dallas I
went there for like three semesters and
then one day I called my dad from the
parking lot I was like I was living with
him at the time and I was like okay so I
don't know how to tell you this any
other way but I'm about to go in and
drop out of all my classes and he had
actually paid for that semester for me
and was kind of baffled he just got this
like long side just it's pretty
disappointing and he's always been very
like pro college pro get it like learned
something that you can go do something
with afterward and I just don't have it
in me I'd go every day and I actually
really like some of the topics like I
loved loved speech I love history and
things like that in English I've always
really had a good time with but I just
didn't have a plan Africa college and
the only thing I really wanted to do was
music and you can get a college degree
in commercial music that you can pretty
much take to nothing so I eventually
just decided to drop out one of my
buddies had already moved out here about
a year before I decided to drop out and
I worked full-time for the rest of that
current year at a private school for
autism in Texas I'm that one of my
friends moms ran and then packed
everything up drove out here and just
kind of hoped for the best I really
didn't have a plan honestly I was pretty
much just gonna slip demos underneath
doors at radios and and I honestly had
no direction I just knew I wanted to
sing and so it's pretty interesting when
YouTube came around and
yeah just became a good way to
demonstrate everything hey guys um what
sort of things you guys would like to
see on this channel and I got a lot of
responses and I was really really happy
with that and one of the things that I
got was to tell the story of moving to
LA and how I started people talk about
how hard things can be and like there
were definitely days were you like I
don't know what I'm going to do but then
you kind of just you're surrounded by
really creative people you're really
inspired by everything and way more so
than I was back when I lived in Texas I
just didn't very uncreated just to the
due to the fact that there was nothing
around that I really related to and then
when I got out here I met a thousand and
one people immediately that I was like
yes yes where have you been all my life
like I've been waiting on you to get
here so it was really nice
again
where the
I still don't really understand it I
like a wake up and I'm like things
aren't going right because I just
knowing that I'm not going into a normal
job I just I don't feel like I'm doing
something that's generating a living and
then every month I'm completely fine and
I'm like okay so I'm here I can still
just make music and everything's cool
okay cool so yeah I don't know but I
mean every day it does become more
apparent that it's time I finally have
the time to give everything completely
which I kind of always have any way but
to know that i can if i randomly get the
did like itch to just drive to Northern
California and sit on a mountain and
write in a journal for four days that
somehow it's going to lead to my job
going better somehow which is helpful
because I do that can I think a lot I'll
just disappear a lot so is all you need
is I would say the most inspiring thing
to me is just meeting other people who
are also really driven I love to just
look up interviews for people who
inspire me Will Smith is one of the
biggest for sure i can watch his
interviews all day and just listening to
how focused and driven he is and how
he's also the outlook on life he has him
and so many of the people i mean you
know just going to shows Jake and I'll
just randomly go out and Hollywood
sometimes and go to hotel cafe and just
sit and watch people we won't even know
who's going to be there just to sit and
watch people come through and play it's
like really really inspiring and they
always have some really good people in
hotel cafe also just going out into the
world I love traveling a lot a lot I got
the chance to go on tour with Julia
sheer at the end of last
and just kidding to see so many people
and like people who knew i was also and
the effect that my music has had on them
is the biggest inspiration to think that
I've ever felt and it sounds really
cheesy to say but it's like you meet
them and they're like this song does
this for me and it really means a lot to
me that you did that and just that
feeling of like knowing that you're
connecting with people and you're
helping them out and whatever they're
going through in life is like reminds me
why I would rather be completely
homeless with a guitar than rich and
like no way to make music
Oh
I think it can be because there's like
so there's so much going on in so many
different directions I think the most
most often I usually I catch myself like
okay how can i how can I find more
subscribers not going to do this and the
most successful thing I've kind of found
to do is just to rather than trying to
bring subscribers to your channel which
you never really want to let go of that
motivation but at the same time like the
best thing you can really do is just
learn about yourself and who you are and
what kind of artist you are and the more
you narrow that down and get more
specific the more people are going to
catch on to it and like in a world where
there's like millions of channels on
YouTube there's you're going to run into
a bunch of people because that's where
all the traffic is and as long as you're
walking through Times Square singing a
song even if everybody else is singing a
song there's going to be people that
walk around that like your song and want
to follow it and you know the awesome
thing is you can subscribe to as many
channels as you want so you can really
feed yourself whatever you want as far
as YouTube goes I just for anybody who
is wanting to create just don't be
afraid to you know don't don't be afraid
to put who you are completely who you
are like out into the world there's
always going to be negative comments no
reason to focus on just if you can
demonstrate what you want to demonstrate
do it much waiting for you
hey guys thank you so much for checking
out my interview here with new media
rock stars don't forget to Like
subscribe favorite everything share it
on Facebook you can check out all the
interview stuff pictures video at new
media rockstars calm and you can go to
facebook.com slash Cory great music
youtube.com slash official corey gray
and my twitter is that for you great one
so tweet me I'll say I to you I love
Twitter stay on it all day so yeah I'm
check me out thanks guys
you